turning now to our next guest she is on
a mission to tackle food insecurity in
south florida
through her non-profit i love the name
of this it's called health in the hood
asha walker's transformed eight vacant
lots into large vegetable gardens
the group distributes free produce to
neighborhoods known as food deserts
where it's difficult to get fresh food a
mobile farmer's market also provides
information about cooking and healthy
eating
in her 2019 ted talk walker talked about
the challenges
facing people who are surrounded by
unhealthy options like
fast food and people who live in food
deserts are the most susceptible to
these options
because they are readily available in
their communities
so what does that look like on the
ground it looks like families that are
stuffed
but starving they're stuffed
because they've consumed highly caloric
meals they're starving because those
meals contain little to no nutrients
and instead are packed with sugar and
sodium and dangerous preservatives
if you live in a food desert your
priority is the price tag
not the ingredient label now the cdc
says
your zip code listen to this for a
second can have a greater
impact on your health than even your dna
what
food deserts contribute to a number of
chronic conditions including
heart disease diabetes and obesity and
only on cbs this morning
health and the hood founder i love the
name of your company health and the hood
founder that would be you ceo
asha walker joins us at the table thanks
asha it's really good to see you welcome
it's so good to see you
so i like this part where it says that
this is surprising to me that your zip
code can have a greater impact
on your health than your dna what does
that mean exactly
it means that where you live completely
dictates the kind of food that you have
access to
it's really that simple if you're living
in a neighborhood that is cut off from
healthy fresh greens
you're not going to be able to
consistently eat healthy food and you
get diseases like
which you say are preventable
preventable diabetes
heart heart disease stroke obesity
they are totally preventable and
oftentimes linked to diet
so how did this come to your attention
asha because you know i look at
neighborhoods and if i see a
empty parking lot or a
dirt you know filled with nothing i
don't see beauty in that you look at
that
and you see what i see a community asset
i see an opportunity that's not being
taken i see an opportunity for a
vibrant vegetable garden so for us
creating a sustainable resource in a
community that doesn't necessarily have
them
was a really simple solution to a big
problem so you literally go knocking on
doors
that's it take us through your pitch
it's you and your dog sometimes me and
my dog cause we gotta make sure we're
safe
yeah but we'll knock on doors as we're
really community engagement is a huge
part of what we do so we're
knocking on doors we're finding out what
people are interested in what do you say
to
them hi i'm asha what do you say just
that hi i'm asha this is bailey and
we're going to be growing some collard
greens across the street
are you interested in anything else in
your neighborhood do you have any
growing experience and do you want a job
because we're also
creating jobs for residents in
neighborhoods that are food desks how is
the pandemic affected
of these food deserts you know it's
interesting people who live in food
deserts were already struggling to
access food and struggling to access
healthy food
so this really only exacerbated it and i
think the biggest difference is that
there are just a new population of food
insecure individuals so it's a whole new
audience
of folks that are not able to access
healthy food asha i was shocked whenever
that there are hundreds of food deserts
in south florida
alone how big is this problem and
michelle obama brought a lot of
attention to this when she was in the
white house like
10 years ago what kind of impact did her
work make
and you know how bad is the issue now
well we're moving the needle but
michelle really sort of opened the door
for all of us and were walking through
us
food and security warriors were
following in her footsteps
and you know our work is trying to move
the needle to make sure that we are
increasing opportunities to access to
real food
but it's it's still a struggle and in
miami there are over 300 food deserts
and this is another type of pandemic
that we're dealing with when you got a
food truck you say it changed the game
for you it did what happened
it made us mobile so we've got nine
farms in south florida this made us be
able to connect them
reach other communities and to have
people come on board and make it a
really interactive experience so
our mobile food truck made a huge
difference in our ability to reach
communities
but what is your back story ash how did
you even notice this
honestly you know it was were you food
deprived as a child i was vegetables you
were not
i was not i was a very lucky young
child i had access to all the broccoli i
could ever want yeah but
i come from community-minded service
people and
uh you know we always knew that you
could convert vacant land
into vegetable gardens and for me it was
my drive home from work i've always been
to non-profit work
and from my three-mile drive home from
my office to my house i passed through
neighborhoods where you could access
fresh food you could get all the kale
you want and neighborhoods where you
could get no kale
so the disparity was just too jarring
the juxtaposition was too great
and i said but there's a vacant piece of
land there why are we not using that
and what does it do for the people
there's something that happens with the
people too
yeah when they get to participate yeah
it's incredibly empowering we are
providing and growing a sustainable
resource in communities that are
often thought of as marginalized and
disconnected this is the complete
opposite
do you find people get drawn in easily
absolutely yes we have an innate sense
that connects us to our food and so when
you're
putting your hands in the soil and
creating your own food and working with
other communities
it is this great equalizer we have you
call it an equalizer what do you mean
i always say that i say food is a great
equalizer because we work with so many
communities we have so many amazing
volunteers that come in
when our hands are in the soil and we're
creating food we're all the same
and everybody has to eat and everybody
has to eat and you've got ashawker.com
because you're working on this and
wellness for all of us yes exactly yeah
it's really the bridge so it's my
personal wellness platform and it's
really the bridge between
health and the hood and sharing more
wellness practices with an even broader
audience health in the hood i love that
thank you so much well